child of Ra's al Ghul awaits your return
I'm not going back it's not your choice
hey youtubers its charlie
this week on air we finally got to meet
the League of Assassins dr. Ivo and I've
got some special info on the flash
episode as well as the secret six that
are coming next week so first let's talk
about our favorite moments then I'll do
my review then I'll do the flash news as
well as the secret six so right off the
bat this episode was teased as the
League of Assassins episode it's called
the League of Assassins that's the title
of the episode so I was really blown
away when the character al owal
the first was actually introduced and
then killed in the episode I was kind of
expecting him to be the big bad this
season or at least someone from the
League of Assassins he did mention the
name Talia al Ghul
he didn't refer to her as Talia he
referred her as the daughter of Ra's al
Ghul so I'm guessing that she might be
involved this season quick raising hands
who thinks that Summer Glau is secretly
Talia al Ghul they totally did the same
thing during Dark Knight Rises Marion
Cotillard character was masquerading as
a businesswoman who later turned out to
be Talia al Ghul
so Summer Glau businesswoman involved in
Queen industries it totally could happen
remember how she hooked up with Bruce
Wayne and Dark Knight Rises so if Oliver
totally hooked up with Summer Glau this
season we'll take that as a sign the
other big thing we got to see in this
episode was dr. Ivo we're not quite sure
what is in that green serum he's
developing we just know that that is
what brother blood is using to weed
people out based on what he said to Sara
I'm trying to save the human race I'm
guessing that it has something to do
with Amazo in the comic books and the
venom vein serum right now all of you
who have been commenting on my arrow
videos that is the number one theory
that it is either venom or somehow
kryptonite related kryptonite is the
number two theory but I think the venom
is just more likely or some sort of
super soldier serum so in case you
didn't catch it at the end of the
episode there was also a teaser for next
week's episode - that's what they're
taking a road trip to Russia so when
you've already pulled that bottle of
vodka out that friend who told him to
have a drink it was basically somebody
we're gonna see in the next episode but
next week is actually the secret sixth
episode we'll see Amanda Waller and
Deadshot the team arrow will travel to
Russia to save Diggle after he goes
missing looking for Deadshot road trip I
call Shotgun I'll post that video right
after the episode airs but be sure to
subscribe to get it and let me know what
were your favorite moments and when do
you think Sara will be back she's
obviously a big part
of Eros story this season she's
definitely gonna be back before the
season finale I don't think she'll be
back before we see the flash though that
is actually coming up really really fast
I'll talk about that episode in just a
second but first what did I think of
this episode overall I'm gonna say this
episode is a solid beat it introduced
two new characters and then promptly
killed one of them it didn't really do a
great job of developing the Amazo the
flashback storyline we've gone back at
least a couple times now with Sarah on
the boat and we still have no idea what
she was doing with dr. Ivo obviously she
was probably just helping him out and
kicking prisoners in the guts
but we still don't know how she got from
the boat to the League of Assassins
so obviously that story has to be told
at some point maybe when Talia al Ghul
makes an appearance I love Paul
Blackthorne in this episode as Detective
Lance
he is so great at playing these just
broken men every single show I've seen
him on it looks like he's running on
like four hours of sleep and someone
just punched him right in the chest
think of him as being like a very very
dark version of Commissioner Gordon so I
still have two really big questions
after this episode one
what does Talia al Ghul want with Sara
obviously they have some sort of
connection that goes beyond that of
master and soldier and why are we still
focusing on Maura Queens trial I'm
really hoping that that storyline meshes
with the brother Bloods storyline at
some point because right now there's
really no reason for that character to
be on the show more a Queen's character
she's really not serving that much of a
purpose but now to the flash so the
flash episode is coming December 4th it
was actually co-written by Geoff Johns
who's a famous flash rider the title of
the episode is the scientist so
obviously it's going to have something
to do with that particle accelerator
they keep teasing in all the episodes
it's definitely gonna be fun but we will
see Grant Gustin who's playing Barry
Allen turn into the flash and put on a
flash costume in that episode it's gonna
be amazing
in other news I'll be posting my next
American Horror Story coven video
tomorrow morning I'm also going to be
posting a special Doctor Who video
remember this is like a month of Doctor
Who so I'll be posting a couple of
Doctor Who videos a week so it'll be a
lot of fun right now click here to watch
all my arrow season 2 videos there's
been a lot of stuff going on this year
especially lots of canary which I'm
really excited about and you can click
here to watch my latest supernatural
video it was hilarious thanks so much
for watching see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you